empecemos dibujando el al que no más
sencillo y eso es poner 2 carbonos con
un enlace doble y después nada más
agregar todos los hidrógenos de cada uno
de los carbonos ahora veamos un arcano
con dos carbonos tenemos por aquí dos
carbonos y como es un arcano tienen un
enlace simple
y por lo tanto cada carbono tiene tres
hidrógenos
tres hidrógenos
ahora cuando estábamos viendo la
nomenclatura de los arcanos dijimos que
esta molécula se llama eta no
y si te fijas tiene la terminación a neo
que denota que este es un arcano o sea
que tiene puros enlaces simples y el
prefijo es de que son dos carbonos
entonces sí nos vamos a esta molécula
que es un al que no que tiene dos
carbono pues tiene sentido que su nombre
sea el de que tiene dos carbonos con la
terminación en o
que denota que esta molécula es un al
que no o sea que tiene un enlace doble
ahora podemos fijarnos en la fórmula de
estas moléculas y aquí tenemos dos
carbonos c 2 y 6 hidrógenos h 6 y en
general los arcanos cumplen con la
fórmula c n h2n2 por otro lado el eterno
tiene 2 carbonos c 2 pero únicamente
tiene 4 hidrógenos y bueno los al que
nos en general cumplen con la fórmula cn
h 2 en otra cosa importante aquí es que
el etano tiene todos los hidrógenos que
podría llegar a tener y entonces se dice
que está saturado de hidrógenos entonces
el led a no está saturado saturado
a diferencia del eterno el eterno no
está saturado de hidrógenos porque
podría haber alguna reacción química que
hiciera que tuviera otros dos hidrógenos
pero bueno todavía no llegamos a esa
parte de la química el chiste es que el
eterno no está saturado y entonces
decimos que está insaturado
y esa
grado más adelante en algún vídeo vamos
a ver cómo todo esto de saturado
insaturados se relaciona con las grasas
saturadas o insaturadas pero bueno
mientras tanto esto de saturado o
insaturados tiene que ver con la
cantidad de hidrógenos de la molécula
mientras tanto vamos a ver un poco de la
geometría molecular vamos a ver cuál es
el estado de hibridación de estos
carbonos este carbono pues tiene cuatro
enlaces simples entonces este carbono
está sp3 y brin izado y lo mismo sucede
con este otro carbono y cuando los
carbonos están sp3 civilizados tienen
una geometría molecular detraer y acá ok
sus átomos forman un tetraedro entonces
tienen una geometría molecular
tetra
rica por otro lado estos dos carbonos
tienen un enlace doble y dos enlaces
simples entonces están híbridos a 2 sp2
estos dos carbonos están libres a 2 sp2
y los carbonos que están libres a 2 sp2
tienen una geometría molecular tribunal
plana para que toda esta molécula es
completamente plana cabe en una hoja de
papel y por eso tiene una geometría
trigo en él
trigo en el plan a
plana entonces además de la forma de la
molécula otra cosa muy importante es el
tipo de enlace que tenemos aquí este
enlace todos los enlaces de esta
molécula son enlaces de tipo sigma que
permiten libre rotación entonces esta
molécula tiene un montón de con
formaciones distintas y tiene
sobre rotación rotación por otro lado
está otra molécula aquí tiene un enlace
sigma y un enlace pib que conforman el
enlace doble y los enlaces que no
permiten la libre de rotación entonces
el eterno no tiene
tiene libre
libre rotación rotación okay los enlaces
dobles no permiten rotación bueno vamos
a ver más ejemplos de al que no sé si te
fijas aquí tenemos dos carbonos y puros
hidrógenos y lo que vamos a hacer ahora
es cambiar uno de estos hidrógenos por
el resto de la cadena a la que llamamos
r pero para eso necesitamos mucho más
espacio entonces tenemos dos carbonos
con su doble enlace y tenemos algunos
hidrógenos
pero aquí en lugar de poner otro
hidrógeno vamos a poner un enlace a
digamos que el resto de la cadena a la
que estamos llamando r ok y como solo
estamos reemplazando un hidrógeno por
alguna otra cadena
entonces le llamamos a este al que no
mono sustituido mono de que nada más
estamos sustituyendo un hidrógeno y
bueno no nos vamos a quedar aquí podemos
poner otro al que no
2 carbonos con su enlace doble y ahora
en lugar de sustituir únicamente un
hidrógeno por algún otro grupo funcional
vamos a sustituir dos hidrógenos por
alguna otra cadena y entonces como
estamos sustituyendo dos hidrógenos este
es un al que no he sustituido pero bueno
obviamente no nos vamos a quedar aquí
tenemos otros dos hidrógenos que podemos
sustituir entonces ponemos por aquí dos
carbonos con su enlace doble y tenemos
aquí un hidrógeno sustituido por algún
otro grupo funcional
y tenemos dos grupos funcionales que no
necesariamente tienen que ser igual a
éste y para denotar eso vamos a ponerle
una prima a estas erres y bueno esta ere
que es distinta a estas otras dos erres
le vamos a poner dos primas y aquí si
este carbono se va a quedar con un
hidrógeno y como sustituimos tres
hidrógenos entonces este es un al que no
ha sustituido y supongo que te imaginás
a dónde va esto
en este al que no vamos a sustituir a
todos los hidrógenos entonces en total
estamos sustituyendo 4 hidrógenos y por
lo tanto este es un al que no te trae
sustituido ahora la pregunta es de estos
al que nos cual es el más estable y
bueno resulta ser que entre más grupos
al kilos tenga entre más sus
constituyentes tenga más estable resulta
ser la molécula así es que este al que
no te tras sustituido es el más estable
más estable
estable y el siguiente más estable es el
al que no tris sustituido y luego el di
sustituido y al final el mono sustituido
ok porque resulta que todos estos grupos
al kilos ayudan a deslocalizar la carga
de electrones ok es muy parecido al
efecto de hiper conjugación aunque bueno
eso involucra un montón de matemáticas
cuánticas y cosas que no vamos a ver
ahorita pero que vamos a ver un poco en
el vídeo del carbó catión y bueno en ese
vídeo indirectamente vamos a estar
explicando por qué este al que no te
tras sustituido es el más estable bueno
ahora veamos dos ejemplos de al que nos
y determinemos cuál de los dos es más
estable
uno de los al que nos
y el otro de los al que nos entonces
tenemos que ver cuál de estas dos
moléculas es más estable y para hacer
eso pues nos fijamos en el doble enlace
aquí tal vez sea útil recordar que aquí
tenemos un carbono con su doble enlace
con este otro carbono y también es útil
pensar en que otros hidrógenos hoy por
ahí entonces por ejemplo este carbono
tiene otros dos hidrógenos y este
carbono no tiene ni un solo otro
hidrógeno de este lado tenemos aquí
estos dos carbonos y nada más nos falta
poner un solo hidrógeno así es que esta
molécula tiene dos grupos r sustituyendo
hidrógenos entonces es un al que no ha
sustituido mientras que esta molécula
tiene 123 sustituye entes así es que es
un al que no
3 sustituido y bueno cuando estamos
hablando de al que nos sustituidos entre
mas sustituye entes tenga más estable es
el al que no así es que esta molécula es
la más estable entre estas 2